right on the fingers this is I'm not
thrilled with this smell oh that's
horrible whatever that is Twizzlers 100%
no root beer that's bubble gum to nail
polish and Twizzlers it's glue Oh what
kind of glue it smells very familiar yet
I don't sniff glue stepped a lot of love
you
I know we're gonna get this one no I'm
not gonna get this one it's also sent up
plumbed I like it I like it a lot sweet
starburst II lemongrass cucumber melon
bath and body works oh like late 90s
yeah body were 80 do you lose that
ladies put on their hands lady goose no
sir turn is it dirt oh [ __ ] whoo
Stuart's no good
you
not ready for this this smells bad from
far away this smells like [ __ ] so sir ah
I don't like that one that is disgusting
terrible give me another I'm mad at you
for that one but it smells like pizza a
burnt Italian restaurant just like dead
feet so smells a little bit like
gasoline and it feels like when you pick
your belly button and smell it almost
like my old sofa I might throw up smells
rotten milk please dirty thought
Parmesan cheese piercing hold its hair
on fire that's what it is it a body part
burnt hair and burnt milk done usually
need to tell us if he that is it for why
just be the smell of garbage she's right
great yes so good at this I have a
really great nose yonex may not want to
eat pizza ever again I would not eat a
pizza it's not like that you guys are so
weird Jeff wasaga dare bad day
it was a bad day why David Bowie died
over the weekend and everybody is still
pretty bummed out about it but the plus
side all the memorializing people and
remembered that he had a stellar film
career including labyrinth so everybody
go watch labyrinth r.i.p Goblin King
you
you